i'd like to discuss the seven warning
signs of cirrhosis now there are a lot
of additional symptoms but there are
seven main symptoms that you need to be
aware of so cirrhosis is an advanced
liver problem it's end stage liver
disease
and really what we have is
normal cells being replaced with scar
tissue so the scar tissue comes in
to try to heal the area but the problem
is we also lost function at the same
time now what's fascinating about the
liver is that it has incredible
reparative cells
normally these cells lie dormant until
some injury comes along whether it's
alcohol
nicotine from smoking drugs medication
junk food
seed oils like in corn oil soil oil
which create inflammation or refined
sugars carbohydrates and especially
fructose but you also have viruses too
so some people get themselves into a
situation where they have either
inflammation that's going on in the
liver that becomes chronic or they
develop a fatty liver which then creates
inflammation and it's really the
inflammation that triggers
these very interesting repair cells and
when these cells are chronically
irritated
they develop a very specialized type of
cell called a
myofibroblast now what is that that's a
combination between
a contractile tissue
and collagen which is pretty interesting
that your cell is repairing with this
muscle-like contractile tissue but the
problem is you lose function your risk
for cancer in the liver goes way up when
you get cirrhosis and because the liver
makes about a liter of bile every single
day you're going to get insufficient
bile which is going to affect your
digestion especially fats omega-3 fat
soluble vitamins and the elimination of
cholesterol and toxins because you need
bile as a way to help transport this
toxic material out of the body also
vitamin a is affected your liver
retains and stores a lot of vitamin a so
without a good functioning liver
you're going to be low in vitamin a and
there goes the vision there goes the the
skin there goes your immune system also
iron is a problem because your liver
stores iron so either you can become
severely anemic
or excess iron that is stuck in your
body which is actually quite common can
create more cirrhosis but the liver
being damaged lowers your ability to
retain iron so it can go both ways
the liver stores glycogen which is
stored glucose to help you
go through the night without eating to
help you go from one meal to the next
also certain parts of the body
need glycogen they can't run on ketones
a hundred percent so there's the lens of
the eye as part of the kidney
part of your brain need glucose so if
you're not able to hold the glucose in
the liver then these tissues do suffer
and just as a side note because your
body does need some sugar it doesn't
mean you should consume sugar your body
can make it from non-carbohydrate
sources the liver is also involved in
digestion
carbs protein and fats so that's going
to be impaired also it's not going to
eliminate the toxins fully so you're
going to get a backup of toxic material
in the body and it usually shows up in
your skin
in other places and the endocrine system
the liver makes a lot of cholesterol but
it also gets rid of cholesterol with the
help of bile but if there's liver damage
you can't get rid of the cholesterol so
it kind of backs up into the tissues
also your liver is pathogens so if you
can't do that you can end up with
systemic infections the liver makes
blood proteins so if there's
insufficient protein in the blood
what happens
is we get interstitial fluid you start
getting fluid that's backing up into the
tissues as edema in your lower legs you
start getting fluid retention
around your abdomen like between the
tissues that's called the cities so when
you see someone who has this protruded
belly like a beer belly
it's a liver problem
igf insulin-like growth factor this
hormone is made by your liver it's
triggered by growth hormone it kind of
works similar to growth hormone so if we
don't have enough of this hormone then
we're going to have multiple problems
which involve the building of a protein
also we're going to have certain types
of problems in mobilizing fuel for the
body what's interesting is the liver
converts
a good portion of the thyroid from t4 to
t3 in fact
80 percent of this conversion takes
place in the liver and t4 is the
inactive thyroid hormone and t3 is the
active form so if there is liver damage
whether you have
a fatty liver or
cirrhosis of the liver
it dramatically affects the thyroid and
then you have a whole cascade of thyroid
symptoms on top of that
you need the liver to activate vitamin d
you also need the kidney and by the way
if the liver is damaged
you're not going to have a really
healthy kidney so when one goes they
both go because they work together but
vitamin d needs that liver and so
because vitamin d is so so important in
your immune system in getting rid of
pain
and keeping your blood pressure lowered
you can imagine all the different
additional consequences of just this one
thing right here
the liver also buffers certain hormones
like estrogen cortisol which is a stress
hormone so with liver damage
you can't buffer these hormones so you
get this spike in cortisol you get a
spike in estrogen you see a lot of men
that are estrogen dominant because of
the liver you can't control that there's
another hormone testosterone which
really gets messed up with the liver
because what happens is you get a lot
less free testosterone with the liver so
then you have a problem with someone
with erectile dysfunction so they start
getting on viagra
and they never actually address
the root problem which is the liver and
then we have another
liver function called blood clotting so
without that you bleed easily okay you
bruise
easily you have these red spots you just
barely bump yourself and it turns into
this like hematoma all right so now
let's get into the seven signs that you
may have cirrhosis number one dark urine
one of the functions of liver is to help
to
recycle red blood cells and the
byproduct of red blood cells and so when
that doesn't occur
we get a darker urine okay so that's one
clue
number two
mood and personality changes now why
because with the liver being damaged you
can't break down
ammonium okay so you start getting this
buildup of ammonium into the brain and
it affects all sorts of
neurotransmitters you can actually even
go into a coma okay you could have
inflammation of the brain because of
this ammonium
the remedy that the medical profession
uses is called lactolose and that
actually helps
turn
ammonium into ammonia which is less
toxic to the brain
all right number three we have ascites i
mentioned that that is a fluid-filled
sac in your gut that is not fat it's
it's like fluid that's leaking from the
liver into your abdomen that's a huge
clue that you have liver cirrhosis right
there
all right now number four jaundice the
whites of the eyes become yellow your
skin becomes like a yellowish orange
okay that's because things are backing
up into the blood and the skin
because the liver is connected to the
circulatory system and it's stopping a
lot of blood flow i mean you're also
probably gonna have high blood pressure
on top of that as well number five
you're gonna be tired no matter how much
sleep that you get number six
you have this chronic discomfort in the
right upper abdomen right here right
where your liver is
i had this problem for 12 years i didn't
know what it was
i wouldn't say i had cirrhosis but i had
inflammation in my liver i was in my
late 20s when i finally figured it out
and changed my diet dramatically you may
even have some discomfort that runs up
into the right side through here
number seven itchy hot feet is another
clue that there could be cirrhosis all
right so those are the seven
signs now what do we do about it that's
the next question well
there's a plan that i have for you
number one you have to stop whatever is
causing
the problem get to the root cause okay
whether this is involving
your diet because you're eating a lot of
junk food
deep fried foods fried in
soy oil or corn oil which is the worst
or you're drinking too much alcohol
taking drugs
too many medications could cause to
cause this problem too and so you may
want to get with your doctor and
try to use more natural remedies for
example
there are a lot of benefits
using milk thistle milk thistle is
probably one of the most
powerful
natural remedies for the liver so
whether you have arthritis
maybe you have fluid retention
you should probably look up milk thistle
and see how many different conditions it
helps
and you may be able to replace with some
of your medications but of course check
with your doctor now a lot of people
have too much iron and so one clue that
you have too much iron is that when you
consume red meat you feel worse or
when you
give blood you feel better suspect you
have too much iron i have a lot of
information on that i will put some
links down below but let's say for
example you have an autoimmune disease
of your liver and that's what's creating
the cirrhosis there are some things you
can do about it
one thing you can take which is very
interesting
is you can take a decoy
you can take
actual liver pills okay like bovine
liver pills and just take one before bed
what happens is the antibodies that are
attacking your liver
attack the decoy in your stomach while
you're sleeping and so it reduces
the inflammation of the liver and it
gives the liver a chance to kind of
reset and when you do this over a period
of months it could potentially deplete
these natural tissue antibodies
and help the whole situation okay that's
number one number two
tutka what is takka
i've done videos on this tudka is a very
special type of a bile salt that's
really good for your liver
there's been some interesting studies
showing significant improvement in
cirrhosis as well as a fatty liver as
well as decreasing liver enzymes okay
and i'll put those links down below
you need to take at least 750 milligrams
to 1500 milligrams you can split it up
take through the day take it an empty
stomach
but i think you feel a lot better when
you take this if you have cirrhosis
because it really
opens up and allows the bile to flow
through the liver and it gives the
person a lot of relief with their
symptoms that they have
is this going to totally cure your liver
i have no idea but it can definitely
help the situation the next natural
remedy is toe katrina's this is a
special vitamin e
group of
compounds
which
work like 50 times stronger than
tocopherols and it's really good at
breaking up fibrous tissue scar tissue
and if you
research tocotrienols with cirrhosis
you'll find some interesting data i
would take at least 300 milligrams per
day
number four cruciferous
why because
people with cirrhosis start to build up
estrogen in their bodies they can't
eliminate it so you need something that
can help
boost the enzymes to detoxify excessive
amounts of estrogen
as well as other toxins there's a lot of
phytonutrients
in cruciferous vegetables and the liver
loves bitter vegetables so like radishes
broccoli
kale
all really good for the liver and number
five i highly suggest you start keto not
just any keto the healthy version of
keto immediately i have a plan for you
on my website go to doctorberg.com
download it and you can start on that
and finally number six adding fasting to
this can be very very beneficial
not just intermittent fasting but
prolonged
fasting periodically okay like 48 hours
sometimes 72 hours why
because it's going to induce autophagy
this is a state where your body is
recycling
damaged proteins and that's exactly what
you have going on in the liver
so
by clearing out some of these old
proteins in the liver
it can be very beneficial to the
overwhelming inflammatory process
the the problem is there's no drugs that
can fix cirrhosis okay
they can't
because it's more toxins to the body so
people get on the transplant list for a
new liver and in the united states
there's like 15 000 people
that are on the list waiting to get a
new
liver but what do you do in the meantime
right here this right here do this plan
don't do nothing there are things you
can do right now to at least prolong
your life
and reduce the complications
that's occurring and i'm not saying that
you can completely get rid of it it
might be too far gone but at least you
can improve the situation it'll give you
more time to survive longer i think the
next best video which is a very
interesting interesting video that i
have is on this tutka you should check
it out it's pretty interesting i'll put
it up right here
you